je joue au
l'appeler
viendra
nous c'est
vous c'est moi
il est plus riche du monde
bré plus riches du monde
les arbres pleurant de joie
offriront
dans leurs bras
il est plus beaux fruits du monde
ouais les plus beaux fruits du monde
ce
ce jour là
la triste triste déroute crac crac
quelle fille elle est promue où rien ne
bouge se cantonneront de pluie de pluie
et le riz le blé ou le rat parfaite
au fond des greniers sans d'orly et
jaune en rouleaux complotait de bach et
de colliers joli joli
le jour la pluie viendra
d'où son toit et moi
les plus riches du monde
les plus riches du monde 2 les arbres
pleurant de joie
offriront dans leurs bras
les plus pauvres et
les plus pauvres du monde 2
ce jour là
sur la